それから解脱と出家というところ
出家とは家では家ではありません
もう一つで必要ですけどね
家でではありません 生きるべき道
苦しみを乗り越える道を選んで歩むことが出家なんです
逃げではない 家出ではないんです
生きるべき道を歩むことなんです
これが定義です 仏教の人は歩むべき道を歩むことが出家です
それはたまたま俗世間の生き方と違っただけの話です
たまたま俗世間の道とは違います
たまたまではなくて 当然違います
しかし 覚えてください
仏教はわざと俗世間と違ったことをやっているわけじゃないんです
まあ当然ながら みんなやっていることと違うことをやっているだけ
それは当然なことで 社会は先生じゃないんです
だから前悪口言ったんです
私は世間の出家の師匠が社会人なんです
仏教の出家の師匠は社会人ではありません
誰の話も聞きません 無知な人の話を聞きません
ブッダなんです 悟った人なんです
だから いまだにも我々は
皆様はどんな批判しようと
ブッダに合わせてみるんです
ブッダの言葉に合わないと
はい さようならと いまだにブッダが生きたままのように我々に指導しているんです
だから 誰にもどんな力も入れて
私の生き方を変えることできないんですよ
ブッダにしかできません
えーと どうなったっけ
社会を嫌うわけでも 非難するわけでも
社会から逃避するわけでも
逃げ隠れするわけでもないんです
負け犬ではないんです
その反対で頂点に挑戦するんです
出家は その通りでしょう
だからお釈迦様が悟ってさっさとすぐ説法し始めたでしょうね
社会から離れてないんです
祇園精舎やら舎衛城やらもうお寺が出来上がったし
もう国の首都のほぼそば
ちょっと歩いて行けるところでいるんです
それから雨が終わったら
置きが終わったら みんな中を歩くんです
それが出家の道で逃げてないんです
いつでも一緒にいるんです
しかし 出家です だからお釈迦様は全部情報知ってます
どんな家で何があったかとかね
だから人が悩んできたらね
あなたね 知ってますか？のなんとかなんとか
人の家でね こういうことあったでしょ
そういう風に話すんですよ
だから世間の出家とはものすごい違いなんです
俗世間の生き方と比較にならない努力と智慧と自己制御が必要な生き方なんです
出家は頂点に挑戦するんだからね
エベレストに決めてください
エベレストに挑戦すると並大抵の努力でできるものじゃないんですよ
だから仏教で出家する人にとっては
もうかなり努力 比較にならない努力をしなくちゃいけないし
それから智慧と自己制御
かなり必要になるんです
お釈迦様が道を発見して解き明かしたんです
だからその道を発見したんです
八正道ですけど すごい簡単で教えてもくれたらくれれば
そう これどう読むんですか
老若男女 老若男女区別なく
誰にでも理解できるように
実践できるように語られたんです
すごいことでしょう 誰にも発見できなかった道をお釈迦様は発見して
誰にも実践できるように語るんだから
達したことがない山の頂上に初めて達するのは大変難しいんですよ
一度も制覇したことがない山の頂上がありまして
それは初めて人が制覇すると
頂上に登るっていうのは大変な厳しいんです
道も何もない もし頂上に達した人がロープウェイを造ったら
誰にでも登れるんです
お釈迦様はそれをやったんです
涅槃という誰にも達することはできなかった頂上を発見したんです
それからロープウェイを造ったんです
ロープウェイを造ったんだから乗っていけばいいんです
釈尊が説かれた仏道は涅槃という頂上に達するロープウェイです
仏教というのは涅槃に達するロープウェイなんです
人間皆出家しなさいという話にはならないんです
だから だったら老若男女にならないでしょうに
登山キットがなくても頂上に登れるようになっているんです
で 形の出家っていうのは登山キット
お釈迦様は登山キットを持って登ったんです
大変苦労したんです それからロープやりますからね
私はこの山にしたんです
お釈迦様は古い町というたとえで同じことをおっしゃっています
悟りに達した出家の男女
在家の男女  500人 1000
人単位でいるのだと釈尊が説かれているんです
時々お釈迦様に攻撃したことあるんですよ
あんたの教えはすごいんだけど
達した人が一人でもいますかと
あなた以外はと言ったら
一人 二人  10人  20人じゃないんだよと
100人  200人ではなくて
1000人でも 1000人
2000人で数えてくださいと
これは出家の男 出家の女
在家の男 在家の女 みんないるんだよと
だから仏道は涅槃っていうのは特別出家生活っていうことにも限ってないんです
仏道を歩むために 表面的にある特定の形を取らなくてはならないとはと言えば非論理的です
ある特別な服を着ないと
ある特別な形を取らないと悟りませんと言ったら馬鹿馬鹿らしいでしょうに
では この深遠なる教え
完全無欠の実践を在家のみで完全に実践するのは難しいので
釈尊の足元で出家して出家いたしますという経典
門戸の意味は何かと経典を読んでみると
ラッタパーラ長老もそうでしょうし
ブッダの経典を聞いてから
お釈迦様 この深遠なる教えを完全に理解すること
この完全無欠の道を完全に実践することが在家ではできませんので
出家をお願いしますと
でもみんな出家した みんなではなくて
大勢の人々が あれってどういう意味ですかね
私は今 出家する必要ないと言ったでしょ
それは専念できない 完成できないという意味でしょ
あれもこれもやったらね
どちらも中途半端ですよ
それだけの話です 王として統治しながら修行に励むと
どこかでどちらか疎かになるんです
例えば ある王様が王様としてしっかり統治をやりながら
しっかりと修行も完成するぞと思ったら
どこかで疎かになっちゃうんです
だから在家には仕事多いんですよ
だから中途半端なんです
どう見たっても だから一つ選びましょうということになるだけ
中途半端では何にも達することはできないんです
出家と社会人には自分の立場にふさわしい義務があるんです
義務を果たさないでサボることは非道徳です
社会に迷惑にもなります
社会人なら義務があるんですよ
この義務を果たさないでいるならば
これ非道徳ですよ 社会に迷惑なんです
義務を完全に果たす気持ちが気持ちはなく
できればサボりたいと思う人は
独立した出家生活で自己管理で修行を完成するとはありえないんです
よく気をつけて読んでください
社会は嫌だ できればサボりたいんだと
できれば仕事したくないんだと
そうやってサボりたい気持ちの人が
では出家するぞと ダメです
仏教ではそんな人は だって出家したら完全自由だから
独立しているんだから
自分の責任自分で見なくちゃいけないんですよ
誰も見張り役ないんです
鞭を持って修行しろ 戒律を守ろうとか誰も言いません
だからもう俗世間の義務をサボる人なんかは
出家はもう迷惑なんです
そういう人は社会に迷惑でしょ
仕事しないんだから 義務を果たさないんだから
そんな人は出家したっても迷惑なんです
ですから 悟られる人にとっては
在家解脱 両方の仕事は大変なことになりかねません
悟られる人として書いたんです
いわゆるやることは完成する人
途中で諦めない人 その人は在家でいると
在家は完成するんです
全部義務を果たすんです
出家したらそれも完成するんです
だから仕事を完了する人は仕事をたくさんこうやって囲んでぐちゃぐちゃしません
あー嫌だ あー嫌だ あれもやらないと
これもやらなかったとかね
それはしません しっかりと
あ こういう仕事を完了するぞと
かかった仕事は完了する
あれもやりたい これもやりたいということで
なんだかな 人格は だから仏教で出家許可するのはすごい人格者
ものすごいもう勇気があって
もう腰抜けではなくて
もう決めたらやるという人々なんです
在家では第三まで聖者になれるが
最終ステージのアラハン果はできないんです
だから在家でも悟れます
聖者の第1 2 3 まで行けます 4
だけ残っちゃうんです
それ全然問題ないんです
第一に悟ったら必ず悟れます
必ず四まで行きます それは問題ないんです
しかし この第三になると
欲も怒りも何もないんです
欲も怒りもなくて商売できませんだからね
結局は だから在家の人が商人であっても
不還果に悟ったら仕事を他の人に任せて
自分がもうずっと戒律を守って清らかな気持ちでいるんです
であのあなたはね もう何て言いますか
もう社長が言わない 行かないとあれ話はまとめませんよと言ったら
いいいい あなた方はもう頑張ってくださいと
仕事をまとめたらまとめたでまとまらなかったら
まあそれはそれでいいんじゃないんですかということでいるんです
しかし 死ぬ瞬間でそれにも達することはあり得るんです
例えば 在家の人が第1 2 3 まで悟ったとしましょう
4 には行かない しかし
その人は死ぬ時来るでしょ
ベッドでもう何も身動きできない状態になるでしょ
その瞬間で瞑想して阿羅漢果になる可能性あるんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想はかなり慣れてる人が
仏法僧に対して本当に信頼ができている人が
死にかけたらすぐ瞑想に入るんです
何とかして治してくれと言わないんです
ちょっと放っておいてくれと
私はもう手遅れだからと言って
ヴィパッサナー瞑想を始めるんですよ
その時 死のその瞬間だからね
結構成長する だから普通瞑想は頑張ってください
ずっと 成功しなくても
もしかすると真瞬間で第一の段階ででも悟れる可能性は大いにある
はい 出家の意義 頭を剃ること
黄色い衣をまとうこと
特別な生活習慣を持つことだけでは
出家者比丘尼とは言えません
それはお釈迦様の言葉
今日は紹介できませんだけどね
えーと 仏道は一切を捨てて完全たる自由に達することです
何かに依存することは自由ではないんです
解脱じゃないんです だから一切を捨ててる
それが仏道なんです 何を捨てる？煩悩を捨てるんです
例えば持ってるカバンを捨てるって
あんた持ってないんだよ
初めから あなたのものじゃないんです
お金を捨てる 初めから持ってないんだよと
死ぬ時はどうせ置いておきますから
捨てるのは煩悩なんです
私の金という あの執着を捨てるんです
形はどうであっても 欲
怒り 無知 嫉妬などの汚れを捨てることができるんですよ
だからどんな形で制服着ています
着ていても 日本の袴なんだか何だか着ていても大丈夫です
煩悩を捨てることできますよ
服は関係ないんです 髪の毛を剃ってあっても
伸ばしてあっても 金髪にしてあっても
全然関係ないんです そんなのは
煩悩とは 問題は煩悩あるんだから金髪にする
自分にないものを見せてやるぞと
インチキ 詐欺 恐ろしい煩悩なんです
普通はまあちょっとかっこいいんだからやってみたって
それだけの話だったら別にどうったことないんです
出家の家は執着 束縛という意味なんですよ
これ覚えておいてください
出家っていうのは 家っていうのは家族って意味じゃないんです
束縛って意味なんです
束縛から出るんです だから出家なんです
煩悩のことです 家を離れて正式的に形の出家になっても
本当の出家はそれからです
例えば仏教も宗教だから
私たちも正式的に儀式を行って出家になりますよ
しかし あれ形だけ うわべだけ
本当の出家それからなんです
大変です だから出家っていうのは
この 2  30分で決めるものじゃないんですよね
かなり長い時間かけて出家しなくちゃいけないんです
真の出家は不還家になることです
それで時間かけて修行して
煩悩を落として落としていく
それで第３ステージになったらもう出家なんです
家でいたってもしょうがないんです
出家です ただ 普通の家で
在家の方がずっと瞑想して
時間かけて瞑想して どんどんどんどん預流果になって一来果になって
さらに瞑想して不還果になったと
もう出家です その人は
形はそのまんま なぜ煩悩はなくなっているんです
しかし まだ五趣は残ってますけどね
そこまでは 出家に挑戦するものです
だから仏教の出家っていうのは当然正式的な形がありますよ
しかし それが出家じゃないんです
それから煩悩を落とす道を歩まなくちゃいけないんです
いわゆるじわじわ じわじわと出家して進む道なんです
微妙な 何といいますか
ボーダーライン だから微妙でしょう
比丘になることなく 阿羅漢になった
なって涅槃に入られた聖者もいるんです
阿羅漢在家なのに阿羅漢で亡くなった方々がいますよ
一番有名な例は お釈迦様の地球を
死の間際で説法を聞いて阿羅漢果に達したんです
出家しなかったんですけど
お釈迦様はちゃんと親孝行したんです
もう父親も私の息子やることは何でも完璧正しいという立場でいて
その通りになったんです
在家も出家も 仏弟子ならサンガと言うんです
サンガっていうのは集グループという意味で
在家であろうと出家であろうが
参詣している人 仏弟子ならみんなサンガと言うんです
預流果から上の悟りに達した聖者たちは聖なるサンガなんです
聖なるサンガ 預流果から阿羅漢まで
仏弟子たちは聖なるサンガ
他はサンガ 比丘戒を受けて修行する方々は比丘サンガ
心の汚れを落とすことは出家の道です
出家っていうのは心の汚れを落とすことです
心の汚れが完全に落ちたならば出家です
それで出家は完了 あんたは出家ですと
悟った人に使う言葉なんです
阿羅漢果になった人に使う言葉なんです
その時はブラフマチャリアパーリオーサーナン
修行が終わりましたと
何の目的に在家の人が出家するのか
その目的に達しましたという言葉で表現しています
だから私にも最近も聞かれましたけど
なんであんたは出家したのかと
答えがないんでしょうに
一般人に言う 大変な違う世界なんです
すごい智慧が必要で 理解するためには
そこでみんな聞きたいのは
あ 私の母親が私は４歳で亡くなったんだから
それで継母にも育てられて
すごいクタクタ殴られて
ひどい目に遭いましたから
私はもう嫌で嫌でお寺に逃げました
あ なるほど よくわかります
と 何いうの このバカどもたちが
そこで正直にあんた何で出家したの？と聞いて
あんまり意味がないんだよと
それ珍しいことじゃないんだと
私は正直に言うんです
契願果の場合は 勇気のある人が選ぶ道ですよ
だから男ならもうちょっとちょっと難しい道をやりたいんでしょうに
その時でも時々お母さんたちがね
もうどうにもならない腰抜けの子供たちが生まれると
お母さんわかるんですよ
この人はもう挑戦もしないし
怠け者でどうにもならん
だから母の気持ちっていうのは
息子がもう安心に親が亡くなっても楽に生活してほしいという
そうすると お坊さん この子はどうですかね
出家とかね 我々は微妙に避けるんです
そうですね それはそれはいい考え方ですねとかね
しかし すっごく態度が悪くて
もうもう乱暴で もういたずらそのもので
何にも挑戦する子供が見ると
てめえ出家しなさいと
いいよ 嫌やと言うと すごく親切に可愛がってあげて
いろいろ母親よりもすごく可愛がってあげたりするんです
そうするともうお坊さんから離れなくなっちゃうんです
で 出家するんです そういう人々が一応残って
仏教は今まで世間に広がっていったんです
だから出家は逃げの道じゃない
これで話は終了です 出家っていうのは悟りに達することなんです
時間はかなり はい どうもありがとうございます
話は終了です  [拍手]